[Music]
unfortunately we have to end with sad
news for the country tonight matriarch
of the Bush family former first lady
barbara Bush she passed away tonight at
the age of 92
now flags at the George HW Bush
Presidential Library in College Station
Texas are flying at half-staff tonight
mrs. Bush was I've met her a strong
lovely funny great patriotic woman or
family gave her the nickname the
enforcer she had an incredible sense of
humor she served this country with honor
grace dignity and integrity and of
course tonight she's survived by her
husband President George HW Bush they
were married 73 years and we are also
told obviously everybody's heartbroken
but is being supported by this family
and appreciates all of your well wishes
in all of this one of her sons president
george w bush put out a statement
tonight that reads quote my dear mother
has passed on at a age of 92 Laura
Barbara Jenna and I are sad but our
souls are settled because we know hers
was Barbara Bush was a fabulous first
lady and a woman unlike any other who
brought levity love and literacy to
millions to us she was so much more mom
kept us on our toes kept us laughing
until the end I'm a lucky man the
Barbara Bush was my mother and our
family will miss her dearly and we thank
you all for your prayers and your good
wishes tonight the White House says the
president Donald Trump and First Lady
Melania joined the nation in celebrating
this incredible life of an incredible
first lady and our thoughts our prayers
our condolences are with the entire Bush
family and many thanks for her many
years of service to this country one
more first lady barbara Bush died today
at the age of 92